Australia I just started reading the  book during this interview just this  boring book and just started going  through how super jet lag and then I  just said I got this new book found it I  found it outside other than I just  started reading through the book and  then they realized I was committed to  the bit I really had to promote my new  book my first numbers this is my new  book right here my first numbers this is  my new book counting is one sock and two  shoes got three whistles for backpacks  and five flags six bottles bottles of  juice in our ten clocks and then logos  again 11 logo slices net hold oranges I  thought that was weird  13 trophies 14 sandwiches and 15 medals  then got part 2 coming up so 16 through  30 part 2 check it out my first numbers  book everywhere books and underwear  [Music]